so I woke up this morning with some
great news and that is that there is a
new loading trailer loading is one of my
most anticipated movies in 2017 as I
said in my top 10 most anticipated
movies of 2017 video the trailer starts
out as this girl is in this am/pm the
7-eleven is pilfering all the items plus
an open Pringles eat them going around
basically being an [ __ ] any employee
of this place does what I or anyone in
his position would do he was like hey
[ __ ] stop this she flips him around
and straight up almost murders him from
doing his job and Logan comes in stop
there he's like not okay there's still
some cigars because you doubt Logan Meza
trailer continues we really see what the
first trailer pitched which it looks
like what this movie is which is a movie
about family and by proxy redemption
because Logan this dude has had a life
and he's like doing the Solid Snake
thing like I'm not a hero never lies
never will be Xavier is with him he's
like Logan come on help Robbie's like
stop it don't want any of this I love
the line when Logan's like someone will
come along and Xavier is like someone
has come along it's you do you're
supposed to help this girl this girl
being confirmed now is x-23 here 99%
sure she was x-23 now we're 100% 99.9
given the possibility of the point 1
percent chance that she's actually
another character with two closet they
made for the movie but I woke up and
she's after she wrecked someone in a
warehouse she's walking up to the main
guy then you see the shot of her face
and I look here come the claws I didn't
they come out and he's like no no no and
she starts kicking [ __ ] ass I love
the fact that when the claws come out
there's blood on the cloth because a
heel or no heel there would be blood on
the gloves I loved in the Wolverine when
you saw blood on Wolverines claws I
thought that was a detail that the other
x-men movies hadn't had that really adds
to the grit and realism of this dude
with claws who's a killing machine or
this girl in this case now we have some
more blood on some more clothes great
because this girl is supposed to be
saved by Logan you see in the trailer
that this girl is completely capable of
fending for herself but just because she
can kill some folks and kill the people
who were coming after her doesn't mean
she doesn't need to be saved
that's what Logan's here to see Logan's
here to save her from his life and she's
here to save him and give him that
Redemption I'm telling you man I don't
know what route of redemption they're
going obviously it involves dual tech
and fighting seriously Logan x-23
dual tech hundred Rakhal
Breger layered concept among a movie
that's x-men within excellence this is
breaking some fourth wall close up at
x-men comic is like all we have an x-men
fans as some of this may have happen it
didn't happen like this which I think
it's great because that's how I always
saw the Christopher Nolan Batman movies
you know it's like those are the real
account of what happened in Gotham the
comic books and the comic book ish crazy
elaborate movies are the exaggerations
of the trailer like Elijah price and
unbreakable said he's like comic books
are an exaggeration of the truth I think
that's really cool when a movie can do
that incorporate it well and have it
work I do notice something about
Professor Xavier Zhou he's bald but he
has the hair on the back of his head as
Patrick Stewart that was a little longer
than makes him look a little more ratty
and older however an x-men apocalypse
Xavier lost his hair because of the
apocalypse thing and that would imply
that he's bald entirely threw out his
head he would not have hair on the back
of his head ergo this is not going on
the apocalypse timelines what I took
away from that killing it off with that
last shot was how boss is that or she's
got the shades
Logan's driving like he's red and she
has her arm out the window and his blood
on her knuckles I doubt it's because
she's her knuckles up bruised because
she's been punching dudes I'm very sure
that's just dried crusty ass blood on
her knuckles because claws have come out
in wrexham [ __ ] I should call him to
like yet I still not Pringle got serious
I'm at this trailer expands on what the
last trailer showed us it gives us the
same feeling which is like Logan is the
Last of Us / Western story of redemption
that I'm hoping Logan is if these
trailers aren't lying to us if it
actually goes that route but how is this
not mmm my question to you is the Logan
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it there's a Logan look like
the coolest x-men thing ever
and the fact that it doesn't actually
look like an x-men - movie it's two men
and a little lady whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]